welcome to this video round six of the
candidates tournament in County my desk
in Siberia I read that it's really cold
there so you're kind of immediate idea
about Siberia seems to be true at that
time okay so let's say look at this game
Anand playing white against coyoacán are
not obviously in in great shape with
plus two leading the tournament coyoacán
is on minus one hasn't won a game yet
and yeah it's it's not looking like his
kind of ultimate breakthrough
performance to him together a match
against the world champion but let's see
what happens in this game kayaking
playing a form as he usually does and
sorry are not playing in for a fun that
it's also the usual move I'm sorry so
this was this was right about it yeah
I'm not playing you for kayaking e5 and
we go to Berlin defense again nowadays
probably together with the marshal the
main line against yeah against the ruler
pass yet some yeah bit of a shame that I
mean I understand why people play that
all the time on top level but wouldn't
it be nice if someone would just play
for once like let's say f5 or or
something crazy like 94 this is maybe
too much to ask for but there are some
sidelines in the way that are really
interesting I mean leading to bit of a
fight not that the Berlin ism yeah
necessarily a very peaceful opening but
really all the time okay well this
time-honored is allowing the mainline he
goes for the end game and can't we get
this
endgame position very famously
introduced to two absolute top level
chest by chrome leak in his match
against Kasparov in two thousand young
white has many possible setups here the
recent development is the move h3 not
yet playing the Knight to c3 this is
some having some small points I guess if
black now plays a move other than King
yet King e8 actually will lead to the
wood main line I'd c3 King a this was
the very old main line of this opening
even before the days when Kasparov had
to face this is wide against chronic
besides that there's this moves there's
Bishop d7 very important one there's h6
many moves h3 is a little move water
wrinkle but kayaknya is just planking it
anyway and after 93 we get this known
line here in place h5 this is also a
possible set up that black and choose
the pawn just gives to h5 to make it
more difficult for white to play G for
the general idea for white and this in
the structure is to use this four
against three majorities got those four
points against Blacks three points and
ideally what managers to advance those
pawns not allowing any sort of blockade
especially on the light squares here the
light squares is a blank blockading
point and yeah black in the long run
wants to use his bishop pair very nice
and yeah in some cases you can also play
on the queenside you have form its pilot
four against three on the queenside but
with this double porn it's not so easy
to make a passer out of that um we see
the struggle
around around those ideas now Bishop f4
just developing Bishop e7 Group D 1 we
should be six others seems fairly
logical to me yeah no I'm unplaced 95
which is a direct approach he wants to
get to the bishop am simply to not
having to worry about that all the time
and black here has a choice we can allow
the trade on e6 I can yeah I mean
allowing it and take it with the pawn I
can also consider to take on g5 like
that the issue is after the recapture
that it's not such a big deal actually
that you have given up you are your
Bishop your dark squared Bishop this is
not such a big deal against the night
from a strategic point of view this is
even quite okay but it might be that in
this concrete position you have a slight
problem you have played h5 and the
bishop on g5 is sitting very nicely
there for white not making it so easy
for black to coordinate his rooks this
place is obviously not on for the rook
and also route d8 is not possible to
exchange stuff black might play h for
him but how do you actually continue
from them it's not so easy I think black
would happily trade this on g5 if he
hadn't played the H pawn to h5 yeah he
went for a loop to e6 to h6 sorry to to
cover he 6 and allow recapture with the
rook and exactly that is what happens
after rookie one should be four and now
after this why it takes and now the rook
can take on e6 this has been kayak ins
idea with Luke age 62 look at those
moves in more detail after rookie one
Bishop before yeah what if he wants to
make any sort of progress he needs to
push on
the kingside at some point now he's got
basically all pieces in play and there's
not much to to play in terms of
improvement so he just went for it just
goes for it with g4 and TM takes on e6
yeah this position is in fact known it
has been played before and finally
enough both players um you have some
experience especially coyoacán he had
this on the board two times this
position in fact even the upcoming moves
up to group the eight he had played
before on the black side in this
position he had played 95 actually in a
game against kawana in 2012 the game
ended in a draw but white was certainly
enjoying a bit of a pressure so it was
clear that some improvement would be
helpful and in fact this rook da it has
been played um yeah by not back i ah
kadib agree shocked the whole world
elite is playing the berlin these days
we shall playing black in moscow 2013 so
this was an improvement and the white
player was kayaking so a very well known
position to both players kayak you know
it seems has come to the conclusion that
this idea by crucial group t8 leads to
ok play so he just goes for it here in
this important game in the candidates
note the clock times both players play
quickly Janet now exchanged on the 8th
ok I can recaptured a note that so shows
two minutes maybe he was I like getting
some coffee um a rook h1 and now 95 so
rook h1 is the rock dat even was the
novelty actually kayaking himself
instead of exchanging he
had played against Greece Jacques
mentioned played rugby one but Allen's
new ideas at the capture and drew cage
one and to be honest this looks much
more dangerous to me than rugby one
white immediately introduces the CDM to
enter on the back rank and enter blacks
position and it's not only rookie Jade
of course it's more importantly
intending to put it on age 7 and this
can get really ugly if the white rook is
just entering without any specific
counter plane um k aachen now spends
time look at this next move he took like
more than 20 minutes he obviously needed
to remember his his preparation or he
was doing it over the board or in any
case I think he's doing quite a good job
he gets a temple on the bishop yeah and
the bishop who needs to go to g3 you
obviously shouldn't oops give up the e5
pawn so Bishop to g3 and yet he has a
very important moment where again he
took a moment and played g5 and of
course the most critical move is Knight
takes his free just grabbing the pawn
but obviously this was still part of
unanswered preparation and I guess only
I mean even if it's there was just this
reason look the move is a very risky but
even if you look at the concrete moves
it turns out that this move might be too
greedy um have a look at this rook h7
route g6 cover the pawn and then f4 very
concrete play and this starts to look
really frightening for black you cannot
grab on g4 Knight f3 is a very
problematic as Luke g6 f5
it's almost instantly losing something
like that is very simple and in Luke h6
there is just the capture here and why
it is made enormous progress with the
spawn do well black is grabbing stuff on
the queenside but well you don't clean
those tab born so early also quickly and
why it simply has an attack here with
the pawns and the King under yeah under
pressure look at something like that
what can easily enter with the bishop
even the rap on c3 is risky maybe it's
playable I mean computer might be able
to to defend that but I think I Atkins
choice is just better from a practical
point of view and also from a human
perspective as g5 is just at for the
moment preventing the desired move f4
for white to were to advance the pawn so
g5 is so strategically speaking of
finals yeah here um Island plate c4 he
just secures the porn for the moment he
had alternatives he could have played
rook a check check as well and after
King e7 maybe go for the Jeep on but
here there is sunshine light f4 and this
will just lead to simplifications as
white cannot really keep the pawn on e5
yeah if he tries to do that with this
there has ruku six and this is not an
endgame you like us white yeah something
like that just leads to white having
this this week pawn it some all this is
not leading to anything for white and I
think plate um played it better I played
c4 first and now kayak he needs to go to
c3 here nights ago is leading to were
two problems
as why this coming with King f3 and
we'll probably just win there for porn
and with it the game he needed needs to
go here to initiate this counter plane
yeah and here in this position with 25
I'm sorry the King are three first and
roop g6 yeah here night a 2 is
relatively easily dismissed as this now
leads to wide breaking through on the
queenside noting that black ones he
played rook g6 to cover g5 and now a 3
here I think this situation move 25 is
maybe where Arnold's Blake could can be
improved upon rook h8 check is what i
was looking at and i didn't really come
to a completely clear conclusion but i
think why this is a bit better simply
because of the better activity um yeah
and their concrete reasons um if black
goes some the only has two moves
obviously if he goes to e7 this route b8
and something like that and I don't know
it looks tricky to me why does is
entering with the rook and in my book
just seems to be somewhat better let's
say something like that it's certainly
better for white and in some way I'm not
sure how much better it is but what with
the a porn must be better this is just
not very nice I was meant to I meant to
just market pawns um yeah maybe it's
really that out of the check oh there's
King d7 that needs to play to cover the
Queen side but here there is rook evade
and what is plug doing now and move like
Luke g7 is very passive do you want to
play rook g7 hmm I don't know in
addition there's some
practical idea here available white can
play and also e6 check iam yeah the
point being that after the capture I
mean if the King takes check something
like that is quite a problem yeah and c7
is going to fall if they're the pawn
takes however there is Bishop f5 which
is very nicely double attacking two
pieces it's quite funny that black can't
save the piece with Luke h7 so that this
in fact is a blunder check but what can
play when improving move like this and
get g5 next move and like I think is in
big trouble here I'm really not sure
what blacks defenses after the check but
I'm pretty sure that it is more
difficult than what was played in the
game here black needs to be really
careful and has some substantial issues
to solve unplayed a 3 in the game and
the problem is that after night a
four-plex night is relatively quickly
coming to e6 and we see that check after
the next couple of moves in this kind of
setup Black has something that very much
looks like a fortress this weakness is
covered this weakness is covered f7 can
be covered with the King and black young
is just marking time and basically does
nothing but how is why it going to
improve black and also we can put jack
the next couple of moves on the board
yeah
in term here they agreed to a draw yeah
it's it's really a fortress how is wide
ever going to break through here
especially the night is just an
excellent piece in terms of defensive
qualities it keeps g5 protected c7
protected and the king is just on d 70
he's having to cover those two pawns and
white has simply and nowhere to attack
and cannot make any sort of progress
black is basically just just doing
nothing and waits developments but white
has no way to improve yeah not a very
exciting game maybe really wish she had
a chance here when he played a three to
get more with Luke h8 but probably it
took took a while on that so he had his
reasons I guess but I'm not quite sure
why he rejected rook AJ check I believe
it at least from practical point of view
it is probably the the more testing move
yeah okay this after on six means that
Anand with plus two is still in good
shape of course what I aachen is still
on minus one and almost out of it at
some point you need to win a game to to
qualify so after six rounds we will have
a rest Dane tomorrow and the players so
yeah certainly can use the stay too to
somewhat gather new strength for the
upcoming rounds alright thanks for
watching